You just built a web app.
And suddenly, it becomes
an overnight success.
Now, you find yourself
struggling to scale it.
We at YouTube face
the same problems.
I'm Sugu, and I'm going to
talk about how we solve them,
specifically about storage,
which is the hardest part.
On top of this, we
also open sourced
the project named Vitess.
So you can also use
it for yourself.
Vitess is written in Go.
And since Go is an
upcoming language,
I'll also talk about how
that worked out for us.
When YouTube was first built,
we started out very simple.
We had just one database.
Then our QPS started going up.
So we added replicas and sent
some of our retraffic there.
That kept us going for a bit.
Then, we ran out
of write capacity.
What you do now?
That's when we figured out
how to shadow databases.
Once we did this, we
thought we had arrived.
That's when someone came
and asked, what about DR?
I was like DR, what is that?
OK.
We'll work on disaster recovery.
Once we took care of that
and a few other requirements,
we ended up with
something like this.
And at this point, we
had created more problems
than we had solved.
With these many servers, the
problems just multiplied.
The simple operations become
complex and error prone,
and things start to
fail all the time.
And at the same time, the
number of developers went up.
And every push, we
had some toxic query
that would keep taking the
database down or the other.
So this is how Vitess was born.
We had three goals.
One was to automate
maintenance tasks.
Two is to write a
query mediator that
will protect the databases
from bad elements.
And three, make it
such that this big farm
appears as one single database.
So how did we architect
Vitess to achieve these goals?
The first thing we did was
to write a proxy server that
will mediate queries to MySQL.
We called it vttablet.
It actually does some
pretty cool stuff.
I'll give you a glimpse of
what it can do in a moment.
Then we built this
topology cloud.
It's basically a lock server to
keep track of all our servers.
It's the one link.
For open source,
we used ZooKeeper,
and internally, we used Chubby.
And using this, we took
control of common workflows,
like taking servers in
and out of rotation,
master failover, et cetera.
And finally, we
built vtgate, which
is the main server that
the apps connect to.
This server makes
all the databases
look like a collective whole.
Internally, what it does
is to use the pathology
to figure out where to send the
query, which will eventually
reach the vttablet where
the actual work is done.
So what does this proxy called
vttablet do that is so awesome?
So the first thing it does
is connection pulling.
The cost of a MySQL connection
is around two megabytes.
And imagine how much this
would be with tens of thousands
of connections.
And if your app
becomes popular, this
is the kind of
demand you'll see.
The second thing
that vttablet does
is to have its own cache,
also known as the rowcache.
See, MySQL's buffer cache works
well for full table scans,
because it reads data in blocks.
But this is not very
efficient for random access
reads that fetch one
row at a time, which
are typical of
mobile and web apps.
So what vttablet does
is to store such rows
in its own cache.
And any subsequent
reads are first
checked with vttablet's
rowcache before deciding
to send the query to MySQL.
And depending on
your usage present,
the rowcache could
give you an order
of magnitude increase in
your serving capacity.
Vttablet has more
optimizations, like for example,
if a query is executing,
and other identical requests
come in, it just holds
off on those requests
until the existing
query has returned.
Then, it returns that
result to all the queries
that are waiting on this.
And you'd be surprised at
how often this happens.
There are many other
safeguards that vttablet
lets you customize like
blacklisting queries,
or limiting the number of
rows a query can fetch.
You can see the full list
on our documentation.
And finally, there's
the stats module
that exports all kinds
of info about what's
going on inside vttablet.
Our [? SRAs ?] just love this.
Speaking of which, how is
Vitess performing at YouTube?
Well, it's been serving
YouTube's MySQL traffic
since 2011.
And the first problem we
solved was the growing number
of connections.
Our servers now handle tens
of thousands of connections,
and we serve hundreds
of thousands of QPS,
and all of this
at low client side
latency of three to
five milliseconds.
So in short, Vitess is high
performance, scalable, storage
system.
Let's see how it's positioned
compared to other products.
On one side, we have
the relational databases
that give you rich functionality
and data guarantees,
but they don't
scale out very well.
And on the other
end of the spectrum,
we have the NoSQL solutions
that give you good scalability,
but they're not strong on
data guarantees, et cetera.
So what Vitess does
is to push MySQL
a little closer to
the NoSQL datastores
by supporting sharding
and replication.
And along the way we
make some trade offs
on transactions and
data consistencies.
And this allows us to scale
just like NoSQL datastores
while still maintaining some
of the cool functionality
that relational
databases give us.
So this kind summarizes
what Vitess is about.
I'm going to switch
gears now and talk
a bit about our
experience with Go.
We evaluated Go
in late 2010 when
Vitess was just being conceived.
And the main reasons why
we decided to use Go,
well, that one, we liked how
the Go team approached problems.
While everyone else was
fascinated with complexity,
we found that they were actually
trying to simplify things.
And this was refreshing.
And two, we had confidence
in their ability to execute.
And other than this, we kind
of just like those features.
In reality, the true
awesomeness of the language
is something we realized
much later along the way.
So how does Go stack
up against C++.
If you're looking
at raw performance,
C++ will almost always win.
But then there are
other considerations.
Like in my experience, once
a server is deemed viable,
people want it to
just do more and more.
And with language like
C++, the code tends to lose
maintainability as it grows.
And even if you're
a good programmer,
it becomes increasingly harder
to keep it maintainable.
And it starts to take longer and
longer to produce new features.
We haven't seen this happen with
Go yet, and at the same time,
Go's performance is
pretty close to C++.
And this makes Go a better
choice than C++ for most cases.
How about Python?
Python's expressibility
is amazing.
And with Python, you can do
with statements, custom list
comprehensions, function
decorators, and much more.
But these are great
only if you want
to write like 100 or
500 line program that
performs a quick task for you.
What if you want to write
hundreds of thousands
of lines of code
using many engineers?
Then, you start running into
a whole class of problems
you haven't thought of before.
There is this lack of formalism.
When you write a
function in Python,
there's no easy way to tell
what those parameters should be.
There's a testability problem.
It's very hard to
prove to yourself
that a program will not
blow up once it goes live.
And at the end of
the day, Python
is an interpreted language.
It eats a lot of CPU.
So Go fills a
unique gap for those
seeking to write high
performance servers.
It's fast enough that
performance is not a concern,
and at the same time
it's expressible enough
that you can grow your server
functionality without losing
maintainability and readability.
So this is a very brief
presentation of Vitess and Go.
If you want more
information, you
can follow the
links provided here.
Vitess is still under
active development,
but most of its core
features are done.
The project is open sourced.
And you should be able to
download it and give it a try.
We are behind on documentation,
but you can always
contact us if you need help.
And we are very eager.
Thank you for listening
and happy hacking.